what's up full podcast welcome to the
were so full podcast the podcast every
said what's up ooh and a couple of yeah
man's and a couple of there she goes
yeah man we got Lisa Esparza I wrote the
new Ettore right here cold of the year
turning rockin here man he's somewhere
I'm lifting up Echo Park that foo got
kicked out or fighting you have the
pigsty he was living in would say my
that plate was dirty I grew up with
friends their house was that [ __ ]
dirty get measles right there Doug
those actually are herpes outbreak in
that apartment man I thought of
cockroaches but walking out there with
cold sores
it looks like that were they like left
like syrup on the ground and they packed
in the carpet like the house was so
dirty bro like like if you were a black
rose that were aboard like you carry a
roller decent join in there roughly in
it Jerry Rubin I just slept on the sheet
on top of the blankets and everything he
had no windows right there's one window
and then he's a little dirty too huh
yeah they were the same room he slept on
the swingers yeah I don't think my house
are there with that dirty that you
remember a good idea but the next thing
it up but I want to feel like it they're
never cleaned up on no dude it's all
dark in there and like old cat hairs the
trash carrot the kitchen was stacked up
high huh they did not take [ __ ] out and
then there was the addition was tacked
up high but the kind of house where you
did people didn't meth in there but know
what I would have done is I'm gonna go
get our guests but what I would have
done if I was Johnny and Martin I would
have banded together I know they're not
on the lease but they should have
contacted the landlord and said look you
got this guy is destroying this
apartment like there's all this stuff I
think it's not even safe to live there
there's mold spores in the restaurant
yeah be going yeah I'd be like this you
know he's violating his lease and you're
gonna have a mess on your hands when he
moves out and I would have just read it
on and [ __ ] that guy
yeah that guy didn't [ __ ] pull the
good one on those fools thoughtful and
the air B&B it yeah well I think that's
the reason why that dude [ __ ] gave him
the blue - dude man I should do there
being being at the house he said I want
to asked her mom what would happen when
you air B&B it he goes up they would
just sleep and then it would just take
off dog when they leave like the key
under a planet or something yeah man
this were here before the speaker right
I believe so yeah go for it
all right hold on let's make her well
Edwin's on what phone number 5 6 - 7 5 5
- yeah it's the same wounded on cause of
5 5 6 - 7 5 5 earliest 9-1-1 yeah real
quick like if you pick so he picks up o
[ __ ] phone numbers oh no we did it we
can see the arrow cord oh wow we're
gonna cut someone right now and I said
oh we live over are we live or not I see
the error code right well he nobody
gonna call us 71 missed calls yeah
everywhere right here man just came back
from doing Pilates Pilate man no not
amateur now I run was that yeah I try to
I was so we seen you forever man hell
yeah man we could I do a movie bro being
you the odds in cinema that documentary
a little screening down in Burbank don't
like cancer yeah in a barrel cuz it was
cats you were getting a dude they
brought me I'm allergic to cats I
started breaking out you have reached
the voicemail box of five six
[Applause]
what's so fool he's going back was so
cool knowing that but go check out every
without one secretly - show us now Hosea
bro yeah I [ __ ] up I call upon Jesus
was time he didn't pick up the other
hippo is and his number one out there
were without yeah dang Oh Julie - Craig
call chameleons over like it you know
it's cool yeah we'll give you a number
and go call me boy but they never booked
you denied the worst right then what's
fun if you don't have that person safe
you get excited think it's the industry
[Laughter]
what's up ooh dog I'm sorry bad chain
over bro we gave it out we give it out
oh we're doing the war so full podcast
right now with RIA Torres Lisa Rinna and
Eric Rivera and I was calling your
number to promote your shorter San Jose
improv this weekend right and yeah
you're no big like will you leave a
message but then your number you started
giving out your number under that robot
voice man so if you get any calls bros
this dude's I just want to blaze you out
so yeah come on you ever shut the San
Jose improv this Saturday I found Sunday
I think of the my off Cinco there may
have bro Birdman outside bro don't bring
reset the show you excited about the
show man yeah I'm excited like maybe
like a year now bro my first ever ever
happy 4/20 show with you and I we drove
to San Jose and we were to go meet that
manager his house and they open up the
oven you know nothing but big homemade
weed brownies bro like but yeah and then
we went to go smoke Luigi Luigi went
with us and they were to go smoke at the
green
room until I play the most ever smoked
in one day no one on the time yeah I
think so I think with me and you like
man I never spoke with this anybody like
that dude like that for 20 no he's right
we met Chris Doreen that night for the
first time quintet bro
hey brother give me $60 bro happy yeah
and we brothers we proud employees do
you we are usable Eric I don't yeah hey
cuz I the train on it and then now that
it's legal in California I just I feel
dumb going to a store and asking for
something that I don't know like I feel
like it's so advanced now because I've
read the different strains and all the
contractions I wouldn't like it there's
no there's no like starter kit for
people that want to get into weed like I
can't go into the pink and like hey what
do you got and they give me just a box
like this is everything you need they
would know there was no good weed bro
like where I was living and me and
loser-ass chapo we will catch a bus you
go wait for Edward to be at his house
and come back in Cerritos from coming
from coming from San Diego for hanging
out his mom crack his bro yeah and then
he gave and we gave me one side he gave
me an eighth and chap one a there's a
mother for an eighth fool but I tell me
I tax those food on the way home and
when my beak when Edward said the night
and remember Dylan he and then I'm Trent
instead ahead he smokes on but like Eric
but he didn't get lost like you bro he
buckets that he'd locked himself in the
trunk anyway he locked himself you know
in a car - yeah that was whenever like
knife or shooter was shooting people out
of the trunk - yeah and then he was left
in the trunk overnight like that's way
thought he was gonna be safe from the
sniper yeah when he came out of the
truck bro he was like black hello bro
brother you LA so man what's up boo
America help you ever everybody you guys
know whoever is that Wiley's man from
the old days bro again rumor I was
about his number with the old-school
card that he said no I would remember
his shows bro and he did those shows at
that um you know the Filipino show star
never the Filipino store but then it was
our agent but doing I'm just doing
Rivera bro that man in common that's it
company Justin Rivera will order is your
cousin brother Filipino therefore will
order more food than the money we're
getting paid yeah a prime rib know that
fool get like a nuggets not like up
chicken tenders yeah
mozzarella sticks and they still have
this big plate and a plate to go and
let's to go eat afterwards but that was
all free all free we've all done that
though I used to do those banquet halls
like we got no money I like I let me get
to them prime ribs to go I eat them in
the car afterwards yeah that's the best
sometimes when they feed you you don't
even care about the working out in the
stage knowing bad no we would take all
the police home bro man was digging food
out of the trash can I got the mic you
serious yeah you know a little cart with
a people trying to food up The busboy
uh-huh right there I just even smash
cans one time and someone stand up I
think so Edwards over there fool we're
doing a show at the VFW with Gilbert
Escobar and there was a lot of luminol
cares where people were eating and I'm
the comedian Peter Channel walking
around the tables and getting other
aluminum cans put it on his bag and take
them home deposit yeah but only that
Eric his [ __ ] was smashing up in
the club with a comedian strange laws
break still alive yeah he ever everyone
said wife shows up and does that Lotus
festival medic apart I can't
the entertainment brothers very bad he
caught me years ago trying to get me to
book a date on Jerry Springer and play I
can act her on the show because he was
doing that for a while he was doing
Jerry Springer like a town coordinator
would know like okay the father yeah
there was a couple comics as did those
guy right if you look back you find I
mean like Wow or something you could you
could it could just be he lives in a
boat he lives on a boat here I leave the
next comedian up
he lives in a boat no Lake Elsinore over
here
Banerjee Reilly brother Hobart Giggy
Giggy San Diego what's up fools just
watch and game already with your
daughter or what yeah yeah man making
oatmeal for right now she had my phone I
don't even have my phone anymore my
daughter has it at the time so did you
want a moving in game yeah we sat at the
end you watch game hell yeah hell no I
was the [ __ ] I just don't watch you
madman wrong behind you
I just got a ride I was so late like I
started watching extras a BBC yeah that
[ __ ] oh yeah the one with the Ricky's
grades that's the one that came from
hilarious do you guys see the one where
De Niro in it we saw Kate Winslet but
there's Jackson but there is really no
he probably the only funnies doing this
be already those entra knows it
premiered last Friday but
a bunch of my family call me like yeah
we're watching an endgame but it's on on
demand right now it's on HBO now HBO GO
it's called intrados it was about me and
a bunch of comics uh Vanessa Gonzales
Christian Ramirez Rojo Perez and myself
it was a great show man
Rojo Perez yeah Corrigan yeah yeah yeah
hurry give me the usual stellar nazar it
who's that old bro you don't wanna [ __ ]
with yesterday I go missing
oh he's the king - laughs that's in
covering New York bro what happened to
him why they wanted to take him off the
stage and Puerto Rican he was trying to
be an act the funny Latino you don't
know Roman s oh right now if anywhere is
in New York you'll pop out of the bush
anyway let's meet up at this corner he's
there how did you find us in this
because he was doing those some videos
and then that fools all popped out of
nowhere
oh he getting my toes done look at your
mother she's so beautiful the lady
banged up a class and you oughta let me
kiss your hand
you literally pays money like I laid
that for raising the drug that would be
a great comedian
yo they had the Puerto Rican Day
Festival we're gonna make you the queen
and funny we're here talking about
Edward show at the sound of the Year
prom and Eric soya people on the [ __ ]
YouTube are chatting right now are
talking about
DeRay Davis and Corey Holcomb I'll
[ __ ] they were on there's like a
threesome thing going for it was a
lesbian chick that took his lady he
almost got it I didn't see the derail
all right Edward man I know you got to
go back and feed your daughter that
oatmeal oh yeah bro up it will keep
letting the shore out of you man you're
you two that you move you're a fool I'm
a being a pirate or to the house we're
going to pirate your house yeah
you the pirate I'm address something
Ricky the pirate broke boo-boo downtown
Brody's da huh
and then like I I kind of moved out and
we kind of move they moved out I had a
my calendar it's starting to get serious
December 12 was at our wedding
I hired him to do magic room the network
which took all the Pepsi's I've always
had been blowing up balloons another
that guy was supposed to walk around and
do magic while we were out there taking
photos and people were just kind of
milling around before the reception huh
this between is the same setting just
they were changing it to dinner and all
that from the chairs after the wedding
so Justin shows up right when the
reception was right when we were leaving
the church or no church the ceremony and
going outside he shows up does his thing
and I swear after we were done with
photos he was like so uh I had another
gig to go to and I was like yeah and I
was like I didn't ask his stuff in there
but like how much work did he do and I
was like what am I paying for he took
all the been disappearing you know what
the judge it was Chippewa Garcia wearing
pants he had Shantz on at our wedding
long basketball shorts but they were
okay you know funny Haiti care they were
wearing chance at the at the way you
know he showed up for fresh thought it
was sitting in a corner and everything
you say hello to him he's a little cocky
he was a first order rule I need to talk
to the head of man
what I heard al mounted girls hair get
stole the story regarding group womanish
oh I think so yeah did he sell his book
after the way what very right here for
this was down bro if you don't know that
but that's wait no Punk dog well we're
gonna choke this [ __ ] though
whatever food was like battling the
other guy but I liked it was like they
knew your comrades were boxing each
other and therefore just chatting box me
[ __ ] we never say no names bro
you know my teacher here right now is
that internet comics talk to uh to
podcast listeners avid podcast listeners
and ask them who's talking about put
your name and it'll ping let's talk
about you're asking if people somebody
comes up and asks you and they're at
comic and they're asking you what people
are saying about them on podcast don't
tell them about subscriber rate if they
would if they would actually pay the
listeners if they paid him money they
wouldn't snitch your mouth they got
snitched out I mean everywhere we did a
show in DC brought for the National
Council of last I which is now LULAC
which is now something else yeah like
340 you're the host of the thing all day
for them huh yeah I did it like three
four years in a row and then they had me
book the final year and they were like
oh what comics can you recommend I sent
them a list over and there's I hate to
say this but this dude messed up the gig
for me because they I would have kept
booking it and they're like oh we want
ty Revere I was like listen I love ty I
think he's funny but be warned I can't
control ty once he hits that stage and
when I tell you his opening line I just
see all these congressmen and Senators
stand up and they just walked out and I
was like oh I think I lost this game
what do you say
he opened up with somebody push me his
opening I was I got man bingo [ __ ] last
night and I just see Otto Otto dudes in
the suit just get up and leave and I was
like all right I lost here we're for no
corporate yeah yeah yeah but I'm never
gonna tell copy like don't say abs like
just read the room please read the room
just but some some contracts will tell
you that like you can't you know you
can't talk a certain way right if you
get hired for something like that now
some of them I mean I I'm very specific
before he books at corporate gig and I
have to you know like he can be clean
yeah there's no problem there but I want
to know what restrictions are because
sometimes like though you know they
won't want to mention anything political
or they won't want to mention a certain
name or something like that not just
cursing or whatever oh no I think you
can get it with those you can get
political cuz it wasn't Geraldo widows
that yeah and he got political oh no
so yeah the one year where Geraldo did
it and he were a political and they love
them but I'm like you just read the room
the senators there's like this people
there Congress they don't wanna don't
want to be mandingo fought not open with
them because look at me audience there's
only like three african-americans right
in the audience and one of them we like
the main guy for UPS and the other guy
for us and the other guy liked a really
really main guy from Greyhound and the
other guy like a main guy from somewhere
the couple I cut like are
hewlett-packard or something yeah he
controls the west coast
these are big shots over there to work
out the you probably never could do you
remember your name
yeah so yeah I got I got the call the
following you're like yeah we're gonna
put up we're gonna take a break from the
comic okay yeah cuz you know I went back
I did you with it was a Gina Bri own
okay myself and little more the magician
guy that was everything show schwa
mundos three or Telemundo's or CTV one
one of those satellite and he's like a
hip-hop magician bro so wait was i just
Crips eyes and a [ __ ] burger comes up
a blood side anyways he's hip-hop that's
what he was gonna say
you know but um this one showed up man
and he was dressed up like dressed up
bro you know they were not buying it bro
and but everybody was so nice but uh but
a lot of the audience is a little too PC
though I got a call from a through
another stage some woman was talking
[ __ ] about me ready you know oh she
online Johnny and I but and I said how
he must have left because I got an
ovation you missed that right right and
then after that she would attack for my
fans but she didn't see the whole show
good on the parts she didn't like or
some people don't listen to the whole
joke yeah Johnny's little joke about
having a threesome she didn't want to
whatever and they had joy whatever many
men sex and she just kept doing
homophobic jokes and but there was a
bodyguard utterly had bodyguards in
charge of you guys or security give
security I'm not that important yet
security security for our like the
comics you know him an Obama runaway dog
hopeful so as you know the show he wants
a bad you guys are friendly to people
with you the [ __ ] out against the food
rushes out bro Russians are gonna Bob
and we kick our ass I took it to an
elevator and then we went back to our
hotel rooms and we're coming back in our
shorts we cgw yarn and the main lady so
you guys are too good to hang out with
us you know shoes out of here hilarious
they got you they got us out of car sped
off email you when you see her when you
book a short huh for those who people
don't know what it means to book or show
you every comedians like if a comedian
is killing your pretty good it could
yeah a good show but then you put up
with I Rivera right uh-huh and what you
you feel the same craziness and
everybody else huh alright you're up
there no huh oh yeah cuz I was in charge
of that show so I had booked that I felt
like I felt when they left us like
there's not good
and then I felt bad for the next dude
going up after it because you could just
tell everyone was uncomfortable Oh ty
wasn't closing it out no no it was I was
hosting Carmen Lynch went up and cost
birdie right I'm is very funny she's
been on she was on Letterman she's been
on Colbert yeah she's clean and then
Tywin open there was no there was no
massaging it in like I've done corporate
gigs or I'm like I got some stuff that's
a little edgy but let me let me set the
tone first do you have a book that nope
didn't even know Lou you know what
Edwyn kind of had that same situation
remember he did that for the police he
did a show it was a one who that's right
and they had all that controversy with
the Sheriff's Department and racism and
stuff going on but so Edwin gets up
there and he does his regular set which
has a lot it's peppered with a lot of
race yeah jokes not raised
brother-in-law
but yeah so his brother is his
brother-in-law is black and so he has a
lot of jokes about that and so he's got
these these jokes that are kind of
crossing the line right but when you put
it in that context what these people are
coming under scrutiny for their racism
the whole time I had never worked even
Steakhouse again yeah they were they let
they like couldn't laugh they a lot of
them left and they went to the press
because the press was like what the [ __ ]
flowing through you know the old days
would it be that big hook the same way
for the Bowery with a lot des with a
broken again hard to do a gig like that
and you just bow man and it's not going
well you can't fix it then they stopped
him I was like he went to go pick up
they wanted a comment from him and
everything he was in Las Vegas before
they legalized marijuana after his first
show I went to go take a smoke break and
he got stopped by the police and it was
on television I think on carpet again
with our cops I think
hey hey coughs uh did he use a credit he
said he uses it at the end of his show
in Vegas he shows that clip cuz you got
rid of the joint I guess he [ __ ] kind
of kicked it down the drain and that
we're looking for it that's when it was
really illegal and then they let him go
so this week where we have our every
Rivera and we have the director of a
movie with um called el Chicano it comes
out Friday comes off Friday May
superhero there yeah you saw it I saw it
you saw it we see they liked it I loved
it I thought it was I thought it was
dope like I didn't know what to expect
uh yeah no wait wait I'm sorry oldest
boy I say they were the bottom well we
missed the first lady yeah you know when
I came in there I came in there when the
brother looking through all his talking
to somebody about the yeah I seen it
right when it started when media wasn't
the weird wheelchair when George Lopez
the young cop walks up to him with the
stop stencil on it yeah and then you
know he you know Marrero takes off in
the wheelchair right Chicano gets them
and we feel a good burn is Sheryl well
finally but we have a [ __ ] uh any
kind of Latino superhero maybe I'm a
chat in yeah yeah easy cleaning or
something we couldn't have a dude in the
Avengers we couldn't have one guy were
they at least drives them around where
you know we're gonna space all right
Milo tornado guy swish they would have
made that Michelle Rodriguez says she
remember she was in the machete much I
say story oh yeah yes like the like she
worked at the food truck you know but
she had some sort of you know
revolutionaries arm turn into a pistol
right in the other movie that was
different
Oh Sin City yeah I think I thought
Robert Rodriguez gonna come out with
some [ __ ] like that but I guess not that
accumulated my chat they were much at
all
yeah I loved it that was the
blaxploitation style yeah if only we're
talking about know his darkest [ __ ]
black dog does exhibitions in Russia you
ever seen oh yeah and they just fall
over he just looks at them and they just
like he's like that preacher that like
goes like this
Benny Hinn wouldn't have to miss to go
had that show he was a cop in Louisiana
yeah he was like the leader of a dune
rage right yeah [ __ ] you spiders had
spidey sense vision yeah the camera
would change to like oh look his pockets
in that fool was with a shotgun dude and
then some kid was really broke his arm
or something little black kid there's
all black black neighborhood he's only
white be there he starts speaking Cajun
to them he said wait a baby got hit
Billingsley on airplanes huh I speak
jive and then the [ __ ] show has to
end right has to end and they gonna
solve the kid running time because I'm
Stevens to go fat-ass and the rest of
sheriffs have a blues band words to lose
music ever bro horrible dog he Bruce
Willis you get to vote back together and
Johnny Depp has to play guitar dog dead
white boys you're gonna come alone or
what hello and I was like come on we
don't want one no Ron set him up with it
oh it's way it's the killer walk number
one
okay okay cuz you're saying Ron I was
like he did not yeah
number one number one my little Mexican
right here Sam little Bobby sells it at
the place
whenever he's doing a show at a club
he'll sell it that weekend at the club
yeah he didn't get cut out of the
divorce you raised in New York I was
raising you're born and raised
all right no burrows I was born in your
shell queen house it just is like North
Bronx you get credit they move the nurse
down already sell a tepee career over in
Boyle Heights Hills bro Boyle Avenue but
it's but there's a little interested I
used to work at Budweiser lift up the
hill and those were like the well-to-do
pills
hightails know so my mom and dad met in
Flushing and then my mom's and I'm hard
to refuse feels like I'm not gonna raise
no kids in the borough so they move
suburbs yeah but it's North Bronx if you
say Western people think people go oh he
lives up in the mountains of state we
met somebody no password and said they
were from LA and then we're over there
from India Wow Los Angeles area
she said Palmdale first yeah you owe
[ __ ] yeah she was a DJ there I should
have started you name is she she said
yeah let's do pronouns like Canada she
say Canada is Canada
everybody correct yeah she's trying to
be authenticated BT Miranda words and
then I'm all you're probably trying to
say Grenada yeah that's what it was she
was South was it called scalawag or what
a grifter they're like says they're from
someone yeah so just feel about your HBO
said I felt good man I was I was sold on
the HBO because I feel like they're the
only
the platform right now there's doing
anything for Latino comedy anyone yeah
yeah cuz you had your special day I know
George is special and now they've
creating this platform first one was and
then yeah so it's it's it felt good to
like that you know they're reaching out
and they're trying to help out comedians
and put us into a light cuz it's sad
that you go to some of these meetings
they don't know who anybody is they know
George they know fluffy and then after
that's like we don't know anybody I'm
like I said that's your my publicist
even no idea Lucian lumiskin look was
the last eight ninety two dot local
college and of course yak come on now
we're gonna hear [ __ ] first [ __ ]
credit out tomorrow recognize who I saw
that full bro I saw that full burner
picture boy was a little girl then the
mom heard about our show right and the
mom went to my acting class Deborah
Lippmann Deborah Lemon
he'd be all fancy give a relaxing our
name cañedo yeah man and then like the
little girl doing stand-up comedy now
she went to the Laugh Factory um
the Laugh Factory by and by there's
nobody in that factory comedy camp right
and for another she's done performer the
devil bro and if he calls it my Meehan
oh yeah a picture whatever give it a
kiss on the cheek
weird how old is this kid
twelve little da thirteen fourteen years
old they got talked about as well I know
right crack traffic is crazy
my boss came over to a room [ __ ] yeah
because like it's funny with little kids
cuz there was a one little white girl
that kind of went viral for a while yeah
kids right I do I got two kids man
- will you find the time to go to the
road and be a pimp right my darling me
bro Kela Willie hey bro hey bro ask her
she has a friend bro I did I sold you
five years ago with Eva Longoria over
NBC and they were very excited about it
because they were like we want to get I
think I was on television so then they
made welcome to Sweden welcome to Sweden
yeah no they passed on my show I went on
that show because it's more divergency a
white guy in Sweden with white people
so it's you know it works it works right
every year I sit there like this is your
show family sure was a family show yeah
and nothing every dude it's every year I
I see people get their hopes up like
this this could be the one and they give
you wives no you had the show with
Dustin yeah that year we'll with dustin
ybarra we had one yeah Gabriel Esther
had one too yeah
Cheech and Paul Rodriguez had one yeah
Angela Johnson had one and I am Gina
Brianna Brianna was backed by Kevin
James yeah and and then they put a Rican
comedian at the mannequin guy uh-huh he
would be a cop or something all right
again with the V his name's Nick come on
you right yeah yeah right yeah and they
are sin passed away that's what happened
this year - they had those nine pilots
and we got passed on - we had another
one this year
yeah and that was when with Vin Diesel's
company we're still gonna do it we're
just gonna pitch to different outlets
this next time and have a different
writer hey just tell we got no money
well it wasn't sold yet they get ahold
of you do you guys did give me you guys
mess with Hulu at all no well this was
not up to us
no yeah like the production company and
that they have relationships with
certain networks but I think this time
we're gonna go to the cable and
streaming instead we're gonna change it
up from that
sort of we're gonna go differently this
time with a different writer but they
still want to do it so we're still with
one race company any idea how far did
you get though we sold the script and
then we didn't make a pilot that was the
first one that's how first one was what
we did
yeah the first one one see it though it
did you well did you guys get that after
the parents of you for now we don't have
a penalty attached to our we did it oh
no we got paid not to work penalty but
then there's like four people to divide
but after our show got canceled winning
a picked up dusty got picked up
burnished oh yeah Kelly yeah I saved
almost six the world yeah yeah yeah
another one too right
he got a pilot after that I don't think
I got picked up yeah I think I did a
pilot he does pilots every time we look
to a horror movie - it's funny when I
saw him when I watch the premiere of it
and then went open a screen that's it
more fluffy was to do they are sad our
other guest is here yes which would give
shows coming up yeah I'm gonna be a sink
or a mile I know you got people going to
see San Jose but I'm gonna be in
Portland and Harvey [ __ ] yeah waters
tight bro never been [ __ ] yeah yeah and
then uh father would go watch the HBO
now which will go it's you know on
demand flying there oh yeah I'm fine
there all right do they use in a condo
or hotel a hotel okay in Portland in
Portland yeah see that guy I don't think
he's yeah in a car bro how can you move
around by it by subway or [ __ ] my bus
alone your wife my wife might come up
which we're not sure yeah we got to
figure out if somebody's gonna come i
watch the kids cuz we got a family we're
gonna interview the government
having them cuz in the middle with us
okay what's your Instagram Eric I am
Eric Rivera Eri K Rivera if you can't
spell that then I can't help you
what did you come with your little coat
B now I hate ten years man I'll tell you
why if everybody follows me on social
media I send them a free copy my
one-hour special it's a couple years old
it's on iTunes $20 a year for free just
follow me
she's gonna follow him right now man go
follow him get to it again Eric Eri K
Rivera comedy go find me it I look just
like me congratulations Marlo Cruz are
your first audition bro you let me know
you live in a [ __ ] Atlanta bro
there's no way you shouldn't be going to
more auditions come on rockin dad come
on they [ __ ] a [ __ ] film endgame
there that day I didn't go to the bottom
I went to the end of the movie to see he
filmed it I saw the big I let a peach
okay
what's up fool what's up ma'am itself is
already better over here we got the rest
of it Chicano Ben Hernandez way on
instagram man you a busy man
supergirl I think everything doing you
think it's better bless you bro
beautiful thank you I must admit at this
year Chicano I got the late yeah but I
walked off when I got there i sat down
lately got up will you ask
ghetto ass people about a movie they
live or remember the character's name in
the [ __ ] movie now I brought what
happened but Eric Weaver just got
[ __ ] shot but how bad what character
is he [ __ ] that dude so do they saw the
crack in the front of the house got a
wheelchair yeah he's been in everything
can't remember his name well the new we
were there right yeah really so we were
looking for [ __ ] parking bad oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] so lupus we're not banging
around Latino Hollywood we got the man
the myth the legend
so Lopez have a seat you tell your uncle
coming bro we don't even pay rent here
but they load it - yeah it's like a
co-op this place we're gonna coop our
Madrigal and bird crasher it's fantastic
they're like a bunch of comedian they
got together and they piss their money
and and they they are I'm a park and I
started here and everyone else brought
their podcast to the studio and we we
really share the revenue and everything
invite you to do your own podcast Amann
I don't really know a live reload it
won't be able to hear this yeah what has
it el mágico see in the next room Eric
Rivera do something with it Network yeah
it should be like are the octaves
Caucasian Network all right people
sorry [ __ ] can you spare a water
yes yeah oh you know you can get them at
the 99-cent store bro yeah thank you my
favorite store you got the different one
we got Kirkland you got Arrowhead well
we shop is the 89th just 89 99 and
there's something like they're cheaper
than that oh yeah when you get there
they're not everything is 99 cents
a dollar fifty oh really and let the big
of 64 liter of soda you know where'd you
grow up man you I grew up in San
Fernando a separate Valley
I bet we have famous former Pacoima
cellmark have bounced around in the Van
Nuys area too so all the rehab in 1990
with a bunch of guy from Pacoima and
after that for naturally there's a big
troll who that showed up look who dude
you're a bait that was a self nominate
yeah and he'll back us right over it and
you know somebody told me no but his
whole [ __ ] family they're from
Pacoima oh no another do that showed up
Oh Archie Carl all different like
Chicano who look different like one do
look Prieto the other guy knows where oh
one kind of native for the got myself an
and oh man he like green eyes and they
were all talking about doing heroin and
ham same damn what a trip yeah we should
go there's kids a handsome damn was like
that was like our dad they had the horse
riding there and every Sunday you would
go there where donkey in a rehab
there was Samson as soon as you put
anything near his tail by the bud that
full runs anyone move you wouldn't move
bro just tap him right there with a
stick boy get scared what was he doing
at the rear I was he like an emotional
support donkey and funny we're like I
guess he never went for a walk so I just
took him out of the thing it started
walking I get my dog and like there's
other horses and stables you can hear
him the other horse is angry or in heat
that he was passing by they were
stomping and really maybe they wanted it
you know why he oh well out there sounds
like me I start stomping - so what's
about that time from that were you throw
will you grew up I grew up in South
Central LA bro okay
that and that at that time it was all
black there's no 3/8 there's not a lot
of us around you huh now ya know now of
course it's all Latino down there okay
but Crenshaw and [ __ ]
we actually a group well in watts the
NATO then Florencia and no more money
and Florence and then eventually we
moved up to Huntington Park HP HP there
are these super burgers that's right
that was like well we grew up in our
people gardens housing projects in Boyle
Heights
but they were like only one McDonald's
all my tango by the hospital yeah yeah
oh yeah yeah and another one an eighth
and Soto only tumor you remember only to
make downloads yeah for my dad hated
those burgers right so we go to HP and
the super burgers there was nothing bro
both warehouses and factories a my demo
BIOS burgers there but my dad would get
like a big [ __ ] fried chicken meal
it's a little bit like how small the
soldiers were bro you have to share it
with my brother I don't really I won't
say like I don't want extra fries we had
at re-broke and bad so you grew up you
have an imagination to have fun at all
man there was a horse imagine it was
seven of us brothers all boys so we
ain't anything well we you know and all
my brothers they all got hand-me-downs
mm-hmm managed and I got hand-me-downs
for my older brother was sister to where
my brother had me down bro the world or
underwear with sixteen seven brothers
but no sister like for fun party for
Halloween they were just up at each
other bro
I'll be artistic imagine my mom where'd
you get your artistic side from where do
you want to be like something else like
gravel cuz I'm me growing up in the
projects like oil in my I'm like on
YouTube hi Eric
like you a wanted more hard line
everybody would everybody in my
neighborhood will only stay in the
neighborhood like right barbecue is in
the neighborhood in a neighborhood like
that why do you think using a wood
chipper so what how the [ __ ] I saw a
Chicano man you were bad and always used
to us the scene stealer it's a great
movie how will you loot the scene right
now it would just almost [ __ ] me now
right now is your place right now I
don't need the makeup so you get the
script for the audition what's your
first thought when you see this part for
which one every time I know it's gone oh
man is actually I didn't know the whole
story I went on an audition I just got
the one of the scenes and right
did did my thing and then I heard I
don't remember it was a while later and
they said well what'd you do this other
part I said sure
yeah absolutely okay and I read the
script is is great and I didn't know Ben
but you know all these Latinos in it I
said ha man this is gonna be great yeah
and and I'm just so proud and that's why
I'm here because I really want to help
promote the movie I think it's you know
I think it's a milestone for us and I
think it's gonna be really good for that
hint there to see it i fro watching a
movie i watching you know you watch the
other movies in game you are a marvel
movies right you watch it like that but
things like but then i halfway through
he start watching like a little boy and
a 12 year old boy we are like okay
better turn him to come and [ __ ]
Chicago so I'm a leaving once you see
the superhero you want to see him again
you know like um and you know I watch it
a little boy like would you come back
superhero so yeah my liking it I know
it's like um you gotta see it in the
movie like and I like go in there like
judge it against other movies you know
you know you're gonna miss out the great
name of the movie man
and I was telling this to this this
other dude right bro I watched his movie
like I used to watch The Incredible Hulk
right I loved it it was good you know
hello and hello anti paisa message but
you get to get over that memory or the
story like Zorro right that his or oh
the it was Hattie's um old school the
color of Don's from Spain who want to
reclaim America we can't California and
put this the Native Americans back into
slavery they got the gold that's why I
started like that yeah you know it's
it's just it was important to tell a
grounded story yeah man so that we could
really relate as a Latino community even
though it still has a universal message
but it was like and and you know in game
those those are wonderful films but it
just it's all leaned on action it's done
gradual effects [ __ ] Fu's up
fools up and I wanted to have this
really great balance of stealing you
know talking about the culture and the
Familia and and just the relationships
you have with your mother and yeah that
you love and and then just and then just
you have this kind of moment where it
just kind of converts into this
superhero theme and it's cool you watch
your movie Bruhl Olivia the bad guy that
would like cap G right by the rapper cap
G and watch you like old man I hope this
[ __ ] died in pieces that quick
that's the one thing I loved about the
movie is like these other superhero
movies like nobody really gets hurt this
dude is like a person so you have to see
him get messed up and yeah rebuild and
come back exactly there's a human side
to that it's yeah and it's not some you
know gabacho that's a billionaire in a
cave right you know this is the projects
bro yeah bro is his his powers are
within him within his culture his Emilia
what he has to fight for so there's a
human side to it and what's exciting is
you know it's an all Latino cast I mean
it's like I know Sal Sal fortune I'm so
glad we're friends now but I knew him I
mean growing up to see him Marco
Rodriguez from the Zoot Suit x to you
know we talked about Latino Theatre
Company yeah yeah you know last other
that last time it's you can't forget
those people they did I came up watching
on television you know the vet that I
knows we have like it's like almost
three different generations of Mangano's
Latinos working together right from
Marlene 4th day who comes out of New
York to sow Lopez again from you know
from the Latino Theatre Company Marco
Rodriguez it's and then now the new ones
coming up Amy Garcia from Lucifer Raul
Castillo plays Diego plays el Chicano
yeah just a phenomenal cast and it's a
blessing if Emilio
first BG time and it's not like no one's
all of these roles are prominent roles
there's not dishwasher yeah a waiter
there's that summate gunnels waiting in
front of the Home Depot they're all
prominent roles that help
push the movie forward the story forward
I know I'm really proud about that it's
time man how about I did you get the
movies together you know it was it was a
process you know once we finished it it
was it was a it was a roughly about
three years you know it took about three
years because we we generally started
pushing it towards the studio system and
the push that we got was they freaked
out that it was a whole Latino cast you
know Martinez's character they wanted to
be a gabacho they wanted to be a white
guy who had got a name who could help
push help the financing and I refused I
said because each one of those
characters of someone I grew up with all
right and Martinez's characters based on
a homeboy mine that I grew up with
Chicago we always joke like this
Mexicans in Chicago right and people
don't know man like what we're doing
we're doing our HBO special we had to
show HBO statistics of Latinos who watch
HBO or really that different type of
people that go to my show you know and
then we should have a lot of stuff and
I'm I'm trying to find this video right
and there's these two Muslim girls right
there from Morocco and they wear their
little Moroccan you know their Muslim
ladies and they're from Spain it speak
Spanish and the reason I got that I know
them now because they put a video that
went viral because I reach shared it it
was them quoting blood and blood out one
of the pyramids bro right and then right
and then they took a picture they put
themselves in front of the B no he stole
a bill away and then well these [ __ ]
chicks were here last week and there
were two actually the tourists you know
some people go to they go to Disneyland
for the way to East loss and took a
picture from the Beano like this oh my
god forever that is great so yeah we
will understand bro like are our
culture's popular man yeah it's just
popular like when you would her like
when you go to like places like like
[ __ ] a Rotterdam you go over there
bro word up with Al Pacino's of that
town bro when people look at I'm like so
Lopez over there
they see him just staying where they
seem brando bro like yeah what our
culture is the godfather to their cuz
they grew up watching we grew up
watching a godfather so we emulate you
know all those movies broke over them
are like American me notable movies
oriental a they love that she Lennox
when you watch with you were they
quality you bro forever or you mentioned
you from South Central like I was
getting [ __ ] up over there brother I
was realized drugs I think any of the
reason they left me alone will because I
taught them all from Boyle Heights and
from nice clothes and I say blow up blow
right here you got stripes gets Jamie
protective so yeah man it's moving like
that man like people I did movie like
it's gonna like a lot the people in our
lair gonna like you for everybody
everywhere you know here we go watch
let's hope that's cool the pina Wow
Morocco
that is crazy you starting to push back
to change the character white guy and
you gonna keep guns which is amazing
like with like something that says we
have to almost go above and beyond like
he's got to show statistics to get a
special on HBO yeah and this dude I
found him on Instagram he's got to
change his name to sold out every show
is sold out but HBO still needs more
prove it we got to get you on like I
pitched shows all time and it's like I
what happens you know season four
episode and you're like this dude I know
you're not asking these guys I've seen
these stories where these people got
going with have a page and they gave me
a showing you like mm-hmm
Wow okay who's gonna protect ya if
you're gonna go down two or three
seasons down like what's what's how's
the story in and or what what the arc of
the starts like I know it's there was a
famous story with Lena Dunham was she
she talked about she pitched girls and
it was half a page and she didn't even
have characters and oh yeah here you go
and you're like how come I can't get
that yeah I got to tell you what happens
at episode 9 season 5 and they do love
interest you need blood say you need
blood fingerprint from every comedian
the problem is OB
yeah it's true it's true it's like if
it's not if you're like in the studio
system it's not if it's not in front of
their face and it for sure thing
if you know becomes such a business
right and there's a lot of fear about
that but I had to stick to my guns and
you know this this the the base of the
story was
it's very personal me I lost a brother
to gang violence 12 years ago he was
killed and I started writing a memoir
about his life and then eventually
started creating the script form as I
was coming up in the business and and
working on it and unfortunately we had
another tragedy I lost a daughter and
joe carnahan be my best friend say hey
man he's crazy as it sounds I think it's
time to dedicate this to not only to
your brother but to your daughter right
once I took care of my family I got a
blessing from you know my wife Saints
okay we got to finish this thing and I
went to New York and I wrote for four
weeks I wrote 185 pages good bad ugly
and came back with with to Joe with
these with these papers and and with the
story I mean and we had a place out in
Palm Springs we sat down for four weeks
you know we drink tequila shots we
hugged we cried we got these 125 amazing
pages right of this origin story that's
really our first like Mexican superhero
and it's crazy everything in lines you
know it's like a few weeks before we
started prepping once we got the money
my mother suddenly passed away it was a
huge fan of the script and the narrative
and everything and we kind of feel like
here's these you know three guardian
angels taking care of me while we go
through the process and she was really
proud of the fact that you know I kept
it I kept everything real and grounded
right now with with the characters being
what they are so and I'll let you know
cast men in such a bless you have to
make a man well you know I wear the big
ticket buyers when it comes to movies so
oh yeah but I want to go see that movie
in the end game bro and look around me
bro without Mexicans
yeah it's true but it's yet another food
inside - still got ya bro no man you can
tell that when we're watching the movie
like everybody falling asleep and then
black panther showed up in there
excited Brooke you know what bro we
wanna see diversity yeah just yeah right
there how much diversity you wanna see
because we were falling asleep during
the moving I like most my kids they were
talking or kid running around little
[Laughter]
black panther came out you should have
seen the crowd exploded bro exploded I
went first scared now Bruce Lee put out
the [ __ ] nunchucks and [ __ ] into
the Dragon bro well whatever them away
well fit the theory why don't I see you
brother diversity you don't know yeah
yeah it's two men listen it's it's it's
less than 3% they get casted it is it's
we're fighting the good fight less than
3% of Casa latina that have Latino roles
in this industry and but you were over
25% of ticket sales yeah we're a huge
demographic represented
yeah we're not represented it's the only
thing left can you go to beachy
Disneyland anymore it's nice I just took
my normal life but breaks my heart
man he goes there's no signs of Coco not
going to every store trying to find Coco
shirt I was like oh no sorry we don't
yeah we don't have to have anything yeah
really
yeah which by the way that was the first
movie my kid he's seven now
he saw and he got to see someone that
looked like Harris and it was just a man
like I didn't realize the effect it had
on it was at Wow a little skull any
movie bro like when you see your part
you're you're raised it feels good yeah
yes I never forget cuz I never forget
that word because I think I'm when I saw
articles are about I'm the brother the
Green Hornet and Kato yeah yeah then you
find out that in China it was Kato and
Green Hornet
no they cared more about Bruce Lee's
lawyer anything about him so they don't
they got excited
only when Bruce Lee came out and it's
true you little kid bro when you saw
somebody do a karate King or you saw an
Asian guy to move around house I cared
about Kato more to badass man
oh you watched Lorenzo talk to you in a
Willie Barcena
you know any like Chicanos or Mexicans
in the movie they only like in a John
Wayne movie a shade like John he gets
shot 75 times so we get shot one time
and the Chicano only line is you okay
[Laughter]
it's a John with a Nazi
yeah no the no effects are claiming was
a Nazi so you know what's up man you're
like oh you go to downtown LA you talk
to the old old dude that the over there
on about somewhere old bro
guys are that I loathe of the blue now
yeah they're all they have a haze yeah
John Wayne come out here and kick all
the homeless guys in the head so they
were messing up the neighborhood
we come back it's condos here that's
funny don't park at much love will do
and I'll be dead I think I remember him
he was awesome super battle Boulevard
nights the live our nights another one
another one every yeah but bullet one
night brother got me into one of our
nights balloon we're getting the puck
gives his tattoo that's my neighborhood
brought is it really Wow but there's a
liquor store bro and every time I but
was a trouble park anything will park we
will take everything I rollin anything
brought she takes on Diaz bro a box full
of hats cooking why we don't know what
it was they were sold it to the
neighborhood row like has a beautiful
memory watched all my mudflats II wasn't
they what time you were there you walked
out another bro wait yet allergies oh
yeah that was there was obviously answer
and so she did it what she did to beat
it holistically with feeling pain and
like all-natural really yeah because you
had their studies this show like certain
foods will help you fight certain
diseases inside so this is her progress
phase three
[Laughter]
it was Charlie a or dad caster did the
key boil in rappy grandfather he was
telling you the but yeah he goes yeah
man up I was a [ __ ] requisite to be a
boxer positive high school prom with her
out there okay I've ever seen him we
were we thought is Jordan ninety percent
we're all you know older white
Caucasians you know retired I was like
oh this is gonna be interesting
yeah I'll screen the film there and then
just from just from a crowd of people I
see one brown guy coming right now look
Joe Carney I'm like oh my god and he was
there I didn't know you realize he lived
there yeah I saw you I thought this you
brew it I love all your focus and then
when I saw him I got starstruck only
when you see it's good to see a lot of
Latinos that stay aboard a ship or
sometimes like I don't know they were
auditioning a [ __ ] Beverly Hills dogs
or something right I went in there they
have everybody there bro yeah all the
comedian's they want to see everybody
Rudy mirando great [ __ ] Willy purse
and me Paul was there partying right all
right everybody right and then Esai
Morales comes in with his notes and
they're part of you go like this he said
Morales he goes that's it I'm [ __ ] are
you gonna get it
Eastside cute well [ __ ] ugly George I
know yeah but it was like they would
the og gonna be he was on George Rowe
May 3rd people who watch the Chicano
made third man Cinco DeMayo weekend
please come support this is it's bigger
than its parts man it's a movement this
is only the beginning to start tell
Latino stories there's a million of them
then we're gonna do a sequel then we can
do the hot air and up for ya
it was that like plan like I'm gonna oh
yeah second part I like to doing that
guy in the movie man the one that I kind
of lead I don't want to say too much
because he's gonna lead to a spoiler
alert but on the other the other actors
I wonder was in Chicago homey he were
like [ __ ] Alfred of the projects
Alfred of the hood
Oh Marco Rodriguez he's a legend man
watching a movie I wasn't okay he's he's
like a Batman he's out for it watching
him because I don't know his name
Rex I love him cold blood other movies
yeah there goes he like arrow James [ __ ]
he's LJ's almost oh I think he yeah
actually when I went we were both in the
play when Eddie went to New York
Marco took over to go over the role but
you go roll yeah that's how we met so
you wanted original zoot suit play yeah
was that like when you get [ __ ] when
you forget the stage and you know the
crowd reaction well you know the thing
is I had I hadn't seen the place so I
got cast and then and then they said
it's anyone not seen to play and I went
yeah I haven't so okay you want to come
tonight so I come to see the play at the
Aquarius Theatre at that time it already
moved and I said they're not my god you
know I was really it was a just
mind-blowing so what was really amazing
is the the electricity in the audience I
mean you had people coming from Arizona
buses coming from all over the country
to come and see this play and it was
full packed house every night with a
roar of our standing over
every every show it was just the most
amazing thing I don't think I'll ever
experience that again it was a pretty
electric it was amazing and it was it
was you know and and you had Raza who
had never been to the theater I mean
most of the people had never been in the
theater so sometimes you'd have the
pachuco you know when when the when the
sailors come out and beat him up and
some other battle get off you know but
those like it was amazing iconic iconic
you know Eddie well we were talking
about Pepe I think pip is the only one
that he could ever tell Eddie because
you're saying eyes he's really funny
yeah rappy grandpa here to tell of the
chuckles my name is na buckle crazy
movie sometime this year
Pepe night John Sayles film September
October you work a lot I'm all right I'm
starting another movie and about a week
it's a called a Centurion said cool it's
about this actually is gonna be a bunch
of make I know cinema really dancing
horses you know with Mexican music it's
pretty cool okay yeah before Chicano
what else you do uh when I started the
business I was I was I was a stunt man
was a Hollywood stuntman so I got in the
business when I was 21 how I and I
worked my way up I was like start seeing
them paychecks I was like wait a minute
wait a minute I could pretend to fight
then actually really do it and you know
I had it my mother my grandmother raised
raised all six of us there were six of I
was the oldest of six and she just built
him just a work ethic with us and if you
ever had this opportunity to really you
know take advantage of a situation that
that's good for you to take care of your
family you know and and I just knew I
just and I fell in love I had the bug
right right when I was on set he I fell
in love with with you know in the
business and mom and grandma was
supported from the jump from the job man
it's like yeah I want to know who that
what a grip was electrician you know
first 82nd epa's I just I wanted to
absorb it was my school Wow that was my
school so I moved up and then eventually
stunt coordinating second of directing
started developing my writing skills and
learned lenses
I was just absorbing everything I was
the first one there and the last one to
leave okay and and that was my school
and I had mentors like joe carnahan
David O'Russell and they they gave me
this opportunity to start directing
second unit and start telling stories it
was my it was really my film school my
training and that's how it all started
man what is the ratings second unit
what was I what did I what did I direct
yeah with David O'Russell was everything
after three kings so I did a silver
linings playbook American hustle joy the
fighter I did the Fighter 4 for Joe I
did smokin aces the gray no smokin aces
the Brule thanks no one we like spend
enough time telling me bad guys are oh
yeah I get to show us the price did the
scene I think when he just pulls the bro
though we have seen and smokey nation
that you gotta understand bro it's taken
from the good the bad the ugly
uh-huh there's the quiet scene so that's
our ceiling the good buddy ugly where
I'm when they blow up that bridge and
they're putting on sad music and then
every James and I would clean East we'll
take some his poncho and give them his
guy who died mmm you live a low cigar
yes they've seen yeah
you know it's just a lot of time you
know your movies always bro hahaha well
that was that's escapism right that was
what we did is let them especially
growing up you couldn't afford much
especially if you could pay for a ticket
I shouldn't be saying that but you know
you kind of sneak into the other quick
question who is worse than Sam Soon or
Harvey Weinstein Simpson brookheimer
right hi come see if he's the one I came
over the idea of putting a killer s song
for the killer ed movie like yeah guard
you have no right to ask me Oh comedies
like maybe hose car for eight hours yeah
copper dude Tobias Marcel and this kind
this kind of scene when they're picking
out um let's check for [ __ ] that I'm
look at that see a flash dance class
that what do you say well you say bet
all bad tell me I'm [ __ ] freaking off
Flashdance they brought in sir the
button children Sarandon or so corner we
were one of them and anybody no other
girl who got the part and they were like
looking around okay she's a great
actress she's a good actress but it
right in front of a robot I wanna I
wouldn't want to [ __ ] these two get that
one no way are you in a casting couch no
but I did work on chips
yes or no James would actually film you
know that the driving point right there
are [ __ ] um Angela Duncan I leave the
little circle the circle there same area
where they put where they play down in
[ __ ] um and Scarface that was
freedom's town oh I only know that
because I'm the other actor was on Joe
Diaz Park and he said it okay what's his
name Steven Bauer Steven Barstow USA
yeah you started acting young right what
do you mean by yesterday I wish wagons
East so now you do right you direct all
these big movies Somerville is Silver
Lining smokin aces how does it feel when
it's finally your project and your that
you're the guy it's it's surreal but but
but very proud you know it's like then
if you feel like this responsibility
this is my opportunity to go and I'm
getting offers already and I'm and I'm
having a and it's it's not easy you know
you got to feed your family gotta take
care of your familia right but I'm
really and then I talked to Sal about
this even actually Marco last night I
want to stay latin-based right now I
think it's really important yeah bro why
not raise Tyler Perry cuz they all black
what can you feel like you know brother
that's exactly right and it's like why
not it works yeah brother Tyler sit the
Tyler Perry system were you know do we
throw you crazy story come on Eric your
sitcom quit between a white vampire
right the neighbors we got all these
crazy stories you know get-togethers for
Christmas the same the K same concept
that he does but Latin based on the
Latin tip which is really important so
I'm pushing the fact that just trying to
say I'm there are some offers out there
and okay they're really excited that are
there lambaste and and we're in we're
talking right there you go well means
believe we're gonna pitch you right
along yeah bro
- vampire anything that beneath us
budget will be vampire bro we're being
chased by latina 'qs
Tina could have the cross everybody will
say women eggs latina the rather be
vampire killers in my movie Nestor cholo
see anybody who likes corn galaxy sparks
I'll open with a movie better
oh that even choppa Jennifer Tilly's a
bunch of cameras buzzer saludos homie
Mayra straight from Chino Cali
that was an easy movie the casting that
Madam's may see the cast on that movie
oh the rehab Roman when they saw
American me brought up I would have been
any dog really I'm gonna ask Joe
somebody the background will be shot or
after the movie my Ricky American me
Bravo so scary after that movie bro my
brother and I we put him we brought down
our bunk base bro about a brother when I
have that feeling
[Laughter]
what boo
Mather go watch and Chicano right on
dragon over 800 movie theaters that's
right this Friday man this Friday so I
encourage all those people in Whittier
man it's playing at the Whittier theater
theater it's it's in you know McAllen
Texas which is uh Ralph Castillo's
hometown or it's in New York City it's
yeah it's out its out there where New
York these um they're near Times Square
near Times Square there's a there's a
regal theater out there I got some some
hint they out there they're gonna go see
you right now where you gonna go see it
are you gonna go I'm actually gonna I
say saw it last night I've seen
today's AMC AMC theater and burping okay
7 p.m. yeah we're gonna Amy Amy Garcia
and I are doing a QA oh yeah very cool
you know familia Bert Bradley one time
seeds were dragged at what time when 7
p.m. AMC Burbank AMC theaters May 3rd no
night tonight anybody watching live go
to Burbank AMC movie theaters at 7
o'clock go to the Q&A man we got a
support man and 20 men were not watching
the movie man remember that [ __ ] you
[ __ ] Atlanta Street Hawk yeah
I'm funny when I was in seventh of MU
right here before you got here but like
is punished arrow May night to really no
more shorts and roast we trained them
for about we were with for about six
months
yeah before in my real that actually
hero from Mexico when I grew up a
Valentin Trujillo ok I had a wound open
ok head of those what okay he'll address
movie makes that one got real did and
it's the only movie that he did in East
lows it was called el otro lado del
puente it's the other side of the bridge
and lucha vias and then he plays his mom
and his mom his wanna be his mom and who
chipiya and like he was like this kid
that they're like his mom grew up in
East LA and he was trying to be an actor
or singer in Hollywood and he meets all
these crazy people and they told him
where his mom was and he goes to his mom
bro and East Los and like she didn't she
don't recognize she did she'd be doing a
lot of PCP so she's all [ __ ] up bro
and in the song place me lean the
mothers I saw a little sad song plane
but you should start crying dog and but
if you through here please
she's like radar Coco yeah
who looks like the lead actor in a
Chicano he plays his crazy-ass brother
bro who gets beat up all the time
enjoying Latino gangs oh god you're like
everyone horrible solo bro the way like
pink bandana a [ __ ] wearing orange
suit local oh it went through the other
side of the bridge lucha via digital
hero and it's shot in Echo Park area and
area Wow your mom Mexican than me and
say bro come on that was table to the
[ __ ] dumb Dravid theater in the
fiesta for ya son down the knoll walk
the floor and Flo ran and my dad would
blow him cheap [ __ ] over nearby
hot dogs or pizzas the snack bar was
just a snack bar just a movie or eating
yeah we go to we used to go to La Palma
bakery before we went to the Florida hot
mexican means right that would buy a
little box of KFC I didn't my dad would
like keep it warm and put her in them in
the motor
[Laughter]
wd-40 series raw yeah yeah yeah the
sequel for sure we're they're also
talking about an illustrated novel comic
book amen
yeah it's cool you know my son works at
DC Comics all those bobble shows you
gotta fit right in there down he lost
all of them
yeah well cuz that Disney's gonna open
up their own digital screaming yeah oh
they're just too much bro
watching upon the punish of the first
season l Punisher and there's a second
one was like a ramen would you please
turn it to approach it kills about it
yeah we're gonna get it and never let in
to the blind guy wasn't me oh yeah demo
I never got into the fist fury yeah yeah
Nora done Lisa but your movie there was
a movie also in back in the 70s it was
like our economy or car and called
Chicano power or Mahalo power or Mahalo
power house like this it was a Mexican
American immigrant who went to Mexico
and then like just a bunch of kaykai
case Minutemen killing a bunch of by
size and I foo goes over there bro he
puts a red bandana I start [ __ ] them
up
Lily that sounds like mo how the power
is my love I'm sorry yeah no I don't but
I remember that time somebody hope were
some fool yeah everybody she come back
next week will be a co-host co-host
[Laughter]
there you go yeah you're probably on
coke van yeah parties 81 reminiscing
geez man
heavy heavy so you know Instagram for
though people can follow the Chicano
page yeah it's at El Chicano film at El
Chicano film yeah please support man
it's important it's important yeah we
got a support man it's it's always sad
cuz we start scrambling at the end we'll
try to save shows and save but like we
got to just come to jump change
revamp from lowrider yeah yeah
exactly but you know it's a blessing is
you're getting you're getting to see
familiar faces on the screen you know
you can relate to and it still carries a
universal message you know it's about
choices you make in life and and your
loved ones and you know the culture
itself and the community and your
relationships with your with your mother
and it's just there's a very human story
about it yeah so it's and it crosses oh
like I I watched it
I'm Puerto Rican Guatemalan so for me I
was like oh I'm not gonna get this
because it's you know Chicano is may god
but as soon as I was hooked from the
jump that's fantast you see the kid run
down and do bad things have a like oh I
don't know what about the happy good and
it was just amazing to see all these
different shades of brown on screen and
you know and it crosses over so like if
you listen if you're not Becky got oh
you're not you gotta watch it still an
amazing movie yeah yeah yeah and just
like you're saying I mean you got no you
had those those girls out there quoting
you know yeah you know lines from you
know from blood and blood out yeah which
you know we hope we hope that that
continues of this film to you know in
this movie and she kind of always been
around then
yeah the message is we've created this
kind of legend that goes so Row for the
ghetto yeah bro
well I'm sorry brother oh yeah now do
you see do you ever see help another
neighborhood yeah going to the Bronx go
to Chicago New York yeah he doesn't have
a horse he has a chopper yeah he's got a
chopper yeah that did a chopper horse
got an Iron Horse
so yes yeah well he ever become
environmental conscious and get like one
of them hybrid charge it was so full get
tickets and fight and fight you to that
el Chicano film calm and Chicano film
calm and you get final words play man
but you know what man if your kids bring
your kids man yeah why not
because they're that we got go
to myself see scary movie bride and if
the opie knows that come out what is
that grinding yeah that's what I want to
be user-made working I like to keep it
BC bro yeah what tell story went to the
real story there's no message at the end
you know where we all got to get along
[Laughter]
team X Kleenex you know message in white
movies but why do we get a better
message I would you have a movie in
everybody [ __ ] happy yeah ah brother
they put enough people always complain
but you know what bro it was all righty
but I wanted more like be nosy
right although there are no Cubans in
yeah we know Dominicans bro sorry bro my
hair to wear socks it was a New York -
man prove me wrong
that's right we're high heels height
yeah you a chick magnet like Excel when
you were little when I was little now
man I was I didn't have a growth spurt
like how those tiny so girls just oh
he's adorable but no I'm still waiting
for my growth hi the big - I my parents
lied to me - like you could be six feet
I mean everything I realized I was like
what will you see when you were a kid
you going oh [ __ ] did I want to be in
this movie or wanna be part of this team
you know movie that really resonates
with me it's two movies heat once for
warriors Oh sheriff or a movie that's it
baby
that's a word she watched oh [ __ ] with
Jackie Lee
Jake Jake Jake man and I just had the
greatest opportunity less I I directed
episodic television right now and I did
an episode of siren in Vancouver and
Rena Owen who plays who plays the wife
Jake's wife she's on that show so I got
to see them we were warriors yeah the
rapist Brody came with a [ __ ] Chicano
story dolly back to Curtis and if
curtains play smiley in training day
yeah yeah yeah I know I didn't know that
was really Ambrose or later on it's
crazy in another life when I was an
actor I take a little a little nobody
I think a few people know that your
boomer Cervantes it was it was between
me and cliff Curtis for that part I
actually read I read for Antoine Fuqua
at least I had like three Carla
callbacks oh I actually did the table
read oh wow
and they decided to go cliff Curtis but
you know wasn't in Cliff's course a
fantastic actor but again you know we go
back to like it's a hardcore Latino part
and they brought a New Zealander and to
do that yeah but I mean he I'm I'm a fan
and I'm a fan of that film but yeah man
that was one of those films you saw it's
like oh I want to be a filmmaker right
92 or 93 head only the only had more
ease in it I don't know why people
weren't sure and just and it was so
visceral poetry Park where the agents
crazy appreciate you wonder why people
disappear out of the movie but you see
at the end of the credits were some food
yeah shows coming May 5th I'll be in
Portland at the Harvey's comedy club so
come on out know that pretty much enjoy
Perez just there and then watch and
today notes on HBO go HBO now HBO on
demand get some comedy in your life
people don't forget mater
go wasn't Chicano story cell Lopez
director right here by Bank Reid
naked Calif ok Matt this week appeared
on the Reilly casino lake in California
with a 302
label Brown Los Angeles Comedy Store I'm
doing on all Spanish or may 16 over in
California May 23rd 26 Salinas
California meter 31st Fox Theater
Stockton Bob Hope theatres June Burt I
do but I can't do comedy in Spanish I
got booked one time to do it it was
either way no way I got a phone call oh
my god speak so fast that guy yeah
no one told me was a clown I get a call
I know the show you know he's known this
household I got a phone call hey we want
you to do this show is that he's the
Jimmy Fallon of Mexico I'm a try but not
a week all right cool Jimmy Fallon
Mexico let's do it I get to the dressing
room there like that Ethan wants to meet
you there's no signage there's no like
walking in this dude in a three-piece
suit in a clown makeup company and I was
like he's like yeah I know like does he
do clown stuff when I have no now you
talk to normal
wasn't available by no Emilio Rivera did
it I did it yeah we play games yeah they
call me to like we want you to do
comedies gonna be a game you only have
to do like a minute not like I could I
could do a minute I act into a minute
and then when I get that they tried to
change it up on me oh actually like the
play game and I was like what's the game
they're like oh it's like karaoke you're
gonna hold the tray and they put this
stuff on you and he buzzes you it's it's
like a Taser no yeah they were trying to
stretch their tongues like the verse
which abate and I was like now I'm doing
a minute standard doesn't
we got another game with the wooden
guitars like nope I don't even know how
that one is the Mexican woman chupitos
like a drunk woman comedian Greta
famosos so they put my hand like an
incubator with these two like actresses
from Mexico and I still okay they drop a
bunch of dirt and hay on her head no no
this crap in Mexico all right
the other one they just began her hair
put you through hair and makeup tell me
bro and they dropped a bunch of sand on
me and then I saw a scorpion on my lip
Oh scorpions bro serious each other like
Ron's dog and I looked in front and you
could tell that the scorpion we're not
getting along in the [ __ ] doesn't about
my eyeballs started fighting bro there's
no Lord of the Rings by another one man
I don't know where bro I just don't like
a cheerleader dawg really I just want to
be in the room when they pitch that show
it's a talk show
now we're gonna pass but I'm in clown
makeup alright he gets away with jokes
in Spanish that you can't get away in
English you know like like they were
doing a bunch of faces and they you know
how memes are like it's a funniest
picture and he write something funny on
the bottom so there was one photo of a
LeBron James getting a finger to his
nose like this and then and I bother me
that joke he said was anything in
Spanish he said what are you citrus my
like oh wait don't come I better go and
we were told by the highway
it is stuck must go see it is my
Sookie's deadly over there here we got
fired one for Mexico that one is in
America well Sabu is Chicago made 30 go
to a Chicano feels man and go watch the
[ __ ] movie man bootleg it sell it on
gotta better be the number one building
in new this week that's right blow up
like [ __ ] so please I forgot about
soul plane that's the movie that blew up
the Kevin Hart yeah yeah before it even
came out of theaters so I found out that
this promoter that booked me in in in
Seattle that wanted robbed me for like
700 bucks and never got paid I heard
that after after an hour so playing
Kevin Hart went over there and I
gathered want to pay him either he said
that he walked with Kevin Hart holding
him in a headlock of the casino guys are
bad bro but for comedian don't get paid
oh yeah oh yeah
I've been shorted I'm like now we're not
I need I need the full mount yeah bro
yeah miyamura melee smoke me out his
girlfriend flashes me I forget I'm like
over time I'm not like it like come do
Brando here bro just going over there
bro learning everything after those 10
hours and hours standing Oliver craft
service was so cool we're gonna find the
film again you're gonna find the film it
we have tonight
Oh an Instagram yeah el Chicano film el
Chicano film calm yeah and she color
film calm Eric Rivera thank you for
being here bro go check him out this
Sunday in Portland at Harveys comedy
club
how are the tickets I don't think $15
$15 guest list
now [ __ ] you were the guests cheap
[ __ ] but hey [ __ ] yeah
man go check him out man Harvey's a real
real nice Club the plenty of parking in
the streets it's [ __ ] nice it's um
it's it's [ __ ] portly man in have fun
warsaw pool of the oratory tell us
something a 14-3 bellows jokes all right
all right
a laptop man the life Art Center